hello everyone we are pleased to have
you join us for cardinal health lab
exchange welcome to today's live
broadcast the future of laboratory
reimbursements I'm Bob Woodward of lab
roots and all be your moderator for
today's webinar we are delighted to
bring you this educational web seminar
presented by lab roots and sponsored by
the american society for clinical
laboratory science the mission of the
ASC LS is to make a positive impact in
healthcare the leadership that will
assure excellence in the practice of
laboratory medicine for more information
please visit AF CLS org we have us two
important announcements before we begin
this webcast is designed to be
interactive and we encourage you to ask
questions during the event you can
submit questions by typing them in the
Q&A box which can be found by clicking
on the green Q&A button at the lower
left of the presentation window we'll
try to answer as many questions as we
can you can enlarge the slide window by
clicking on the screen icon in the lower
right hand corner of the slide window
finally if you have any technical
problems viewing or hearing this
presentation please click on the support
button at the top right of your
presentation window or or submit your
problems to the green Q&A button on the
lower left following this presentation
head over to the community of learning
in the lab exchange lobby to have the
opportunity to engage in live chat and
have more of your questions answered on
the spot about the future of laboratory
reimbursements I would now like to
introduce today's speaker Lisa
passionate ms Testament is the executive
vice president of the ASC LS she is a
clinical laboratory scientist with over
20 years experience in clinical
laboratories as staff educator and
manager and another 20 years in
healthcare consulting association
management and health policy ms
testament uses her science background
and experience to analyze policies and
systems
they relate to the future of health care
is changing emphasis reimbursement
patient safety quality delivery and
business potential she has served on the
congressionally mandated negotiated
rulemaking committee convened to
standardize and simplify reimbursement
for laboratory services under Medicare
Part B present a testimony to institute
of medicine studies and represents AF
CLS at meetings with the FDA CMS and CDC
she is also on the Editorial Board of
lab tests online she was a member of the
clinical laboratory improvement advisory
committee from 2007 to 2011 and served
as chair from 2009-2011 please join me
in welcoming this passion in today's
event I will now turn the presentation
over to her thank you Bob good morning
everyone we're going to spend the next
50 minutes talking about what is going
on not only in general terms but also in
very specific terms as far as read
reimbursement for laboratory services
and then some of the regulatory issues
that you're all going to be or are
currently confronting it's very
important that we keep up with all of
this because you just never know from
frankly from day to day what is coming
next from the federal government the
critical issues that are affecting all
of us these days include changes in
practice that we're all facing as
because of the structure of healthcare
healthcare is moving for two accountable
care organizations and medical homes and
other configurations that don't always
include the traditional settings that we
think of for practice of health care
we're looking at different concepts for
reimbursement this is a particular of
major concern to those of us in the
laboratory we're used to being
reimbursed by test
and that is something that is we will
discuss shortly is probably going away
we are all faced with a personnel
shortage of one sort of another year and
the way you're coping with it may or may
not be ideal but it may be what you're
doing because you have no other choice
there are some clear regulations some
going to change some that will be
changing and then at the end we'd like
to talk a little bit about the FDA's
guidance on laboratory developed tests
and also if we have time the blood
glucose monitors so looking at changes
in practice one of the first things that
our have hit all of us is the patient
access to laboratory test results this
is something that if you're as old as I
am you know you we've talked about or
vinto forever not to give patients
information about their laboratory tests
and that is all changing as healthcare
has become more patient centric the
laboratory and its services are one of
the last to open or be opened to direct
contact and communication with patients
but it has now happened the PIPA and
CLIA regulations were both modified a
year and two years ago to mandates that
patients get their laboratory results if
they request them they're a
patient-centered care is is being
extended with the concept of medical
homes and frankly that means at some
point we are probably going to find
ourselves hook to these medical homes
these medical homes the way they qualify
is that they are responsive and
available to the patient on almost a
24-7 basis for consultation if we're
going to be part of medical homes it
means someone from our laboratory is
going to need to be able to talk to
either the physician or the patient and
talk about the laboratory test services
they need or have already had and then
they're patient safety initiatives of
the Joint Commission has has been
particularly forthright about and then
evidence-based medical practices which
we provide the evidence for so the
future of CMS is that they're talking
about coordinated care models and the
reason that they're talking about that
and we have to pay attention is because
they're going to want to do
reimbursement around those coordinated
care models so Medicare Advantage or
Medicare Part C depending on who how you
refer to it those insurance companies
that contract with Medicare and to cover
beneficiaries was their first foray into
coordinated care accountable care
organizations and medical homes are
their most current and there I have and
always will talk about episodes of care
trying to get their arms around what
would be the definition of a set of
services or what would it look like this
set of services that are provided when a
patient starts an episode has a clinical
condition that makes them present to the
health care system and frankly CMS is
thinking that you know is there a way
just like they did with the argies is
there a way to pay for the episode in
some sort of lump payment that then gets
divided among those who gave care to the
patient the future is probably the
fee-for-service as we know it that is
being paid for what we do on a piece
being basis is probably going to go away
and that some sort of quality measures
are going to be used to decide the value
of what we did and how much
reimbursement we r do physicians have
already put together quality measures
that have been developed by various
associations to determine what should be
used to measure the quality of the care
that they delivered and the question is
should the laboratory community come
together and do the same thing obviously
it
would be wise if we did if we were
proactive because if we wait it's going
to happen to us the discussion is that
they're going to phase out fee for
service physician groups have called for
this phase out and CMS has been
searching for a new approach if there
are any of you out there who are
currently working in esrd laboratories
or laboratories that work with end-stage
renal disease patients you know that you
have already been part of a
demonstration project that links payment
to the dialysis centers ability to
provide quality care and meet certain
quality measures and that your
laboratory reimbursement got bundled
with their quality measures CMS has
announced that they are planning to move
to other move away from fee for services
and to other types of payment models
there they keep talking about value
based models which they have not really
defined well yet and then the bundle
payment models the one that we know the
best is dr g is for any of you who have
to deal with inpatient reimbursement but
they are looking to apply that bundle
payment model to reimbursements for any
regardless of where the care is given in
the health system the payments will be
based on quality and some sort of poor
nation of care and we in the laboratory
we hold the information necessary to
really make sure that care is
coordinated because we have the IT
systems that can bridge both the care
setting in the physician's office the
care setting in a clinic or even in ergy
center with the care given on an
inpatient basis rit can talk to all of
those settings better than just about
anyone else in healthcare and if you're
I teach can't do that it it needs to get
started doing that really quickly
because the the
we'll are out there already for lab IT
to do that and so are we we hold the
keys to that coordination but
unfortunately we're not always well
recognized for that so our current
strategies of just trying to keep costs
down by increasing volume to get better
margins for our fixed reimbursement are
not going to work if we're not going to
get reimbursed by the test itself but
rather by some other quality measure so
in at the beginning of 2015 HHS Health
and Human Services made an announcement
that they were going to tie thirty
percent of the traditional
fee-for-service Medicare payments to
some sort of quality or value payment
models such as what they were doing with
the ACOs the panel care and that there
would be bundled payment arrangements
for some of this traditional
fee-for-service by the end of 2016 that
is not that far away they want to tie
fifty percent of all payments to these
value models value-based models by the
end of 2018 and eighty-five percent of
all traditional Medicare payments to
quality or value by 2016 and ninety
percent of all hospital readmissions or
a hospital reimbursement to programs
like value-based purchasing and
readmission reduction programs by 2018
there's an additional goal to tie
eighty-five percent of all traditional
Medicare payments which is what we fall
into by 2016 so that means we are going
to end up finding ourselves with new
involved in new negotiations negotiating
things like what's the definition and
the measurements or metrics that are
going to be used to determine that we
provided quality service that allowed
the institution to meet its quality
goals and then
then based on what we show them we did
we have to negotiate some portion of
that total reimbursement because the
hospital or the ACO is going to get it
we're not that's what happens with these
bundled value-based payments it's given
to whatever is considered the parent or
the controlling institution and then
they are supposed to disperse it based
on whatever formula they come up with
and so you each of us at our individual
institutions are going to have to spend
the time to determine or help the are
our c-suite determine how much of that
in payments that they received comes to
us gets charged to our accounts so that
we have the dollars to pay our folks and
to keep the doors open that's what's
coming down the road but the current
reality is that laboratory testing is a
small part of Medicare spending but our
payment amounts have been reduced by
over forty percent over the past two
decades most recently since 2011 we have
seen cuts to the CPI which is a consumer
price index where that were supposed to
get updates from we got a two percent
cut when Congress passed the middle
class tax relief and Job Creation Act
which and it also got rid of the
technical component for pathology
services which was definitely took a
your pathology department took a hit for
that and then there was a two percent
cut to the fee schedule as a result of
sequestration that began in 26 13 and
happened again this year in addition so
the Association for clinical I of
American Association for clinical
laboratories aqua has put together a
graph to show Congress and anyone else
who will listen what has happened to our
reimbursement since 2010
took a sample $10 test and showed the
blue line that you see going straight up
is what should have happened if we had
gotten all of our updates and then
nothing had been frozen and we never
been cut so by 2022 that $10 laboratory
tests should have been reimbursed at
twelve dollars and eighty four cents but
even here at 2015 we should have been
being reimbursed at least eleven dollars
and maybe eleven dollars and change
however thanks to all the different cuts
that occurred and they're represented by
the different colored lines the bottom
line is that and that is the very bottom
is that by 2022 that ten dollars test is
only going to be reimbursed at nine
dollars and eighty-three cents and even
as of today that ten dollar test is
already been cut so we're only getting
nine dollars and fourteen cents for it
so there are no other health care
providers in the system that have
received this level of cuts and that's
why we keep telling Congress I can't
keep doing this however the OIG in 2013
identified they believe that we have
been over Medicare overpaid for
laboratory testing to the tune of
billions of dollars they looked at how
Medicare was paying versus Medicaid
which by the way by law has to pay less
than Medicare so that's really not a
fair comparison and then selected some
insurance companies most of which were
the federal government employees
insurance companies and the military
insurance company coverage which again
are typically reimbursed at much less or
no more than Medicare and did not look
at any of the private their payers that
most of us have to deal with the United
see signals etc so we believe that they
cherry-picked a couple of insurance
companies to make a point that was it
wasn't really valid it was a florid
study but unfortunately Congress
event it in addition they just announced
that as part of their 2015 work study
this is a piece of information that just
came out they will be looking at lab
payments for the top 25 test that
Medicare paid for to determine again
whether or not Medicare is overpaying
and this is not going to help when we
all try to talk to our individual
institutions and try to get some of the
dollars that they're going to be getting
for value-based payment so the issues
that we're facing is the protective the
protecting access to Medicare Act and
what happened there and I'll explain
that in a minute the CMS hops program
that stands for hospital outpatient
prospective payment system packaging of
laboratory tests the molecular pathology
reimbursement and any of you who are
part of that knoweth what a pain that
has become Clea updates and then as I
mentioned earlier patient access so the
current reimbursement under the current
reimbursement CMS was packaging a lot of
tests that I'm sorry a lot of services
that were delivered to outpatients and
paying the hospital in the hospital was
then determining how the money was doled
out laboratory tests and some
pharmaceutical and radiology tests were
all excluded from that initial bundling
but in 2013 they announced that they
were going to be doing that and they
have done that at the end of 2013 CMS
published a rule that implemented a new
policy packages all outpatient
laboratory tests provided on the same
date of service as the primary service
whatever the patient presented them to
the primary care doc for and ordered by
the same practitioner who ordered the
primary service and the only thing that
they carved out of this with molecular
pathology because they believe that they
hit a
adjusted the reimbursement for molecular
tests and that they that could be held
separate and that also most molecular
pathology would not be considered a
laboratory test that was ordered for a
primary care service we explain to them
that there's very little that
outpatients come get in the way of
laboratory tests that are strictly for
primary care that most of the time they
are coming as outpatients for some
existing syndrome and that it's being
followed on an outpatient basis but CMS
did not buy that explanation what they
did do though was give give some
exceptions first of all they said that
they believe that this was going to
moderately reduce payment tootsie roll a
major teaching hospitals because they
weren't going to get separate payment
and that it was for primary care even
though as I mentioned we contended that
outpatient visit so rarely for that
reason so they carved out some
exceptions if the patient is a non
patient that is is not a hospital
inpatient or outpatient then you can
bill for your laboratory services if the
specimen was collected by the hospital
for a lab work only and the patient got
nothing else done that day again you can
bill and if the laboratory tests were
clinically unrelated to the reason that
the patient went to the presented for
outpatient services then again you could
build separately and so far CMS is
defining unrelated as a test that's
being ordered by a different
practitioner for a different diagnosis
and this is causing a great deal of
confusion i'm sure some of you are
struggling with this the other thing
that they came out with that we're all
struggling with is the molecular test
coating they decided that you know the
stacking codes which is confusing and
you know they didn't know what they were
paying for and so the AMA cpt committee
came up with new codes CMS embraced
those codes and said that they were
going to
them into two categories tier 1 we're
going to be codes that they believed for
analytes that are done a lot of a high
volume and then tier two were codes that
were for lower volume and that payment
levels that they then assigned through
their contractors for most of these
codes turned out to be very very low and
very difficult for any of us to do the
molecular testing list because they
weren't covering our cost we also
questioned the transparency of the
covers decisions because they really
didn't give us an opportunity to make
much comment they asked for our input as
to how much things we're costing us we
gave them those numbers and yet the
reimbursement numbers that they came up
with there are no resemblance to the
cost that we submitted so we can't
figure out if they've got calculators
that are missing a couple of numbers or
periods or what's going on here but they
don't seem to know how to do simple math
the other concerns is that Medicare
seemed to assume to be assuming that
there are some tests which admittedly
are primarily performed in the pediatric
population that would never be used for
individuals covered by Medicare and
therefore they're not paying for them
the problem with that is as you all know
Medicare also covers individuals who
have permanent disabilities or are
unreal dialysis so any children on renal
dialysis or who have are permanently
disabled are covered by Medicare and are
therefore not getting the tests that
they need the molecular tests they need
in addition because Medicare is not
setting race for those tests the
Medicaid program think that they
shouldn't be paying for them either even
though the tests do apply to their
pediatric population so we've got we've
been trying along with the association
of molecular pathology and cap and
others to get meetings with the medical
directors of the Medicaid
read the state Medicaid programs to
explain to the Medicaid medical
directors that these are appropriate
tests for the pediatric population and
they do need to be paid that those
efforts have been not as successful as
we'd hoped but we keep working at it the
other thing CMS announced was that they
were going to set new rates for the
clinical laboratory fee schedule because
they believed that there was a need to
that they were overpaying from any
laboratory tests because of the advances
in technology they were going to do a
five-year process and the idea was to
reduce payments the lavatory community
was not delighted because we felt they
were going to do this without getting
our input or use those same weird
calculators if they got our input and so
we needed a legislative fix during the
AFC LS legislative symposium which we do
with CL ma ascp amt and agt we went up
to the hill and talk to them about that
at the same time separately aqua and
asthma men coalition was also on the
hill saying you can't let CMS do this
and as the Congress passed the
protecting access to Medicare act
affectionately known as pama they
included in that a clause that said that
beginning January of 2016 all laboratory
applicable laboratories will send the
Secretary of Health and Human Services
data about what they have been paid on
fee for service for from all insurance
companies regardless of the insurance
company and regardless of the payment
arrangement and that the secretary would
could establish an exclusion for any
small small laboratories or laboratories
who only paid very little paid very
small amounts on fee for service that is
all of their work is capitated that
sort of things so those were things that
the secretary and HHS were supposed to
do in regulation the Senate clarified
that when they said all applicable will
let applicable plans they meant all
independent labs and all Hospital
outreach laboratories that receive
payment on a fee-for-service basis
because there was some question about
whether or not they really meant that
hospitals had to respond CMS was going
to take the data they were going to use
do a weighted median now keep that in
mind not a weighted average but a
weighted median which as you know means
they're just counting into the center
the problem with that is if hospitals
don't supply data and the number of ends
the number of pieces of submitted data
are primarily supplied by Levin's
laboratories the weighted median is
going to be very low so we have a lot of
concerns about making sure that CMS
provides a way for hospitals to submit
the data since it's way more complicated
for them to do it than it is for a
reference lab to do it theoretically
then the CMS would then crunch the
numbers and by 2017 we would be bit paid
on this new weighted median for all the
clinical that all the tests on the
clinical laboratory schedule the
payments amounts would be determined
this way before 2017 through 2022 they
were not allowed to reduce the payments
more than ten percent for the first two
years and then 15 cent percent for the
next three years not really exciting
news guys because you're talking about
twenty five percent reduction by the end
of 20 22 which is even worse than what
we were expecting initially from our
current cuts oh and just so
you know we could feel better I guess
about this they gave us a increase in
our collection fees if we went to
collect from a nursing home or an
offsite of two dollars and up from the
regular three dollars so now we can get
five dollars for that I wouldn't be
buying any new equipment based on that
but that you know and the payment for
new tests would be determined by either
cross walking or grab selling cross
walking means they would take a look at
a test that's already exists on the fee
schedule and see if it matches and if it
does that's how you would get paid and
if there was no existing test then they
would do a gap filling which is when we
submit information about how much it
costs and they're supposed to calculate
the new payment they also carved out or
described a category of advanced
diagnostic laboratory tests for which
they would pay whatever in the
laboratory decided to charge for three
quarters and then in the fourth quarter
they would take a look at what everybody
was charging for that test and if the
test exceeded some weighted volume that
they had calculated then CMS was going
to ask you to give some money back they
defined advanced diagnostic laboratory
tests are that as tests that are offered
and furnished by a single lab and are
not so for you by that lamb other than
by the original developing laboratory
and have are cleared by the FDA's very
most of us are scratching our heads
trying to figure out what tests that
might be but CMS seems to think they
know they also were supposed to
establish advisory panels and those
advisory panels were supposed to help us
we were supposed to be able to give
input to CMS to help them make some
decisions about the data they were
getting and how to do the calculations
and we've all submitted nominees to
these advisory panels we those advisory
panels are supposed to meet as a July
first to date they have not announced
any of the names of the people that have
been
pointed to the advisory panel the pamo
was also supposed to establish payment
rates for all tests and then the general
Accountability Office was supposed to
study and submit no later than in
October of 2018 an assessment of what
the impact of all of the implementation
of these new levels of reimbursement had
on we're hoping laboratory services and
patient access and then the OIG again
was supposed to analyze Medicare
spending on the top 25 test every year
so the OIG has taken that part of Pama
to heart and that's why they announced
that they're going to be doing that this
year they believe that that's their
authority to analyze our Medicare
spending going forward every year but
CMS is still to publish any of their
part of the regulation and in the
meantime pama still let all the cuts
keep stay in effect so while
reimbursement is currently up in the air
because we have no idea what CMS is when
CMS is going to start this project how
we're supposed to submit any data when
all this is going to be implemented
because we've not seen the regulations
in the meantime we also have other
regulatory challenges that we will be
facing FDA's guidance on
laboratory-developed tests Lea's
proficiency testing Clea s CMS is
concerned about how many wave tests or B
are out there the personnel issues and
patient access sorry station access you
are all at this point required to give
patients their or their designee access
to laboratory test results 30 days no
more than 30 days after the completion
of the test and CMS has made it clear
that you can't arbitrarily just wait 30
days if the test result is available
earlier than 30
I'm sure all of you have figured out
some way to do this you are allowed to
let your medical records department
handle this you don't have to handle it
but if you are handling it you are also
allowed to charge okay now the other
thing that CMS is worried about and it's
shown on this slide is the personnel
issue they believed that they are seeing
in laboratories that they are visiting
for inspections Oh shortage of educated
personnel that the hiring practices
where laboratories are hiring
individuals who are not appropriately
educated and certified is raising
concerns for them because they don't
believe that these folks necessarily
know what they're doing they are
concerned that over time there is going
to be great deal of pressure on the
existing personnel to perform the way
they need to and if that is the case
that those pressures could lead to
patient safety compromises somewhere
along the line in addition Clea has also
taken a look at proficiency testing they
are working on modifications of the
current proficiency testing regulations
that are in our in the regulation
because they are credibly outdated
however they have been looking at this
since 2009 it has not been able to come
up with the language that they believe
will work for not only today but in the
future so there's a real concern for
many of us that we're wondering when and
if they're going to ever get updated
proficiency testing requirements out
there but they have also looked at
quality management and the electronic
health record initiatives and the
laboratories role
in meaningful use requirements okay as
far as proficiency testing the other
aspect of proficiency testing that has
been an issue for CMS and for many of
for many laboratories is the possibility
that laboratories either accidentally or
on purpose referred their proficiency
testing samples to another laboratory
for testing and then reported the
results of the other laboratory did the
old clear regulations require that if
CMS came found out that a laboratory for
whatever reason referred PT testing they
had to close that laboratory or suspend
its license which is the same thing as
closing it for two years suspend the
license of the laboratory director for
two years and the laboratory would not
be allowed to do any Medicare testing
that was by CMS his own accounting too
strict and with CMS is blessing laughs
the laboratory community went to
Congress and Congress passed the taking
essential steps for testing act known as
tests for short which gave HHS the
discretion to figure out new sanctions
okay for PT referrals CMS issued their
rule and I that's the website where you
can find the rule and it divides the
sanctions into three categories based on
what they consider to be severity so the
first category was the laboratory
purposely sent their proficiency testing
sample out in that category if it was
done for the first time whenever they
would revoke and suspend revoke the
license to spend this the director for
at least a year the second category was
if they referred it out and received the
results prior to sending in there
answers but disappears to be there the
first time they ever did that then they
could suspend and impose ultimate
sanctions for less than one year but
they would still probably suspend the
laboratory director the third category
where the test results were sent out but
the results were sent to the proficiency
agency before they receive the results
from the referring laboratory that
category would just get alternate
sanctions each category would be subject
to civil money penalties that's
typically started at ten thousand
dollars the alternate sanctions always
included required retraining of the
staff but the concerns were that this
rule still wasn't flexible enough and
did not meet congressional intent
however that is currently what we're
working with there are some valid
reasons or opportunities where a
laboratory will accidentally send out a
proficiency test sample because a you're
supposed to be training in like patient
samples so theoretically your staff
doesn't know it's a proficiency testing
sample and if it is something where
let's say you get one result and then
you send it out for further testing you
would send out the proficiency testing
sample theoretically your quality
management supervisor or whomever that
person is would stop the sample before
it goes out the door but sometimes those
things don't happen that way and that's
why there is a need for some flexibility
and we're hoping that CMS will continue
to house we put it use some discretion
when they when they look at what a
laboratory is done to make sure that
they're not suspending laboratories that
really really did something totally by
accident as far as the electronic health
record is concerned CMS and CDC very
concerned that laboratory ins are not
being engaged well enough
in the design of the regulations for
Meaningful Use and so they have asked
all of us all laboratory associations to
raise their concerns with you all and to
ask you but as the opportunity presents
itself to volunteer to work with
whatever federal agencies or meaningful
use projects are occurring in your
institutions because otherwise there are
going to be decisions made that will not
be appropriate for how laboratories data
interoperability works the next thing
that CMS did do CMS CLIA did do was to
look at the eqc policies they
participated in a process with clsi the
clinical laboratory standards institute
and decided to that it they were going
to replace the eqc policies that
everybody said we're not very good
policies anyway with this iqcp which
stands for individualized quality
control plan the this is a voluntary
thing that you can do you do if you are
doing EQC if you've used eqc for any of
your tests be a point of care be it wave
testing in your laboratory that has to
be replaced with something so you have
two choices you can default to the
current regulations which say that there
has to be a minimum of two levels of
external control per day of testing or
you can try to implement these an
individualized quality control plans CMS
provided interpretive guidelines I have
supplied you with a link to those these
interpretive guidelines are used to
clarify and explain regulations and
convey the agency's thinking and that's
what they have done for iqcp what they
want you to do is develop your own QC
plan based on the risks of failure that
you believe you have identified in your
system
you might start with some routine tests
or some very low volume esoteric test
there has been an education and
transition period that has been going on
for the past year and a half it will be
over in the next six months and then
anyone who has was using eq c must
either go back to the default
regulations as i mentioned earlier or
must have an IQ CP plan in effect it's
meant for non wave and certified lambs
there is a email box where you can ask
them questions about how to do this the
deemed organizations are supposed to
incorporate this into their regulations
however they see fit so if you are
inspected and accredited by either cap
or joint Commissioner Cola you follow
what they want you to follow and you
don't have to worry about this but if if
not the CMS has actually published a
step-by-step brochure giving
instructions on how to implement an IQ
CP plan on their website on the iqcp
pages so if you just go to CMS and look
up the IQ CP page you will see brochures
explaining iqcp and then also a
step-by-step guide for implementation
should you decide to do that laboratory
developed tests are the next thing that
will be of concern for many of us we
don't believe we do laboratory developed
tests but depending on how FDA decides
to define laboratory developed test we
may all be doing laboratory develop
tests and not knowing about it the
agency is really concerned most of all
about companies that decided to form
laboratories to get around submitting
their new products for FDA clearance and
instead call them laboratory developed
tests and they believe that this that
there are tests out there that have not
been whose clinical validity and
clinical utility has not improved
or establish and there are laboratory
professionals ascl SS members are among
them that do share concerns about the
clinical and analytical validity of some
of these laboratory developed tests CMS
I'm sorry FDA held a two-day workshop
and the patient groups that attended all
urged FDA to implement their authority
and figure out what's going on with
these tests because patients are being
told that this tumor marker or this
congeneric marker means that they should
get or not get a particular drug therapy
or that this tumor marker or that
genetic marker means that they will will
are prone to relapses are prone to
metastasis some of them have turned out
to not be true others have been true and
they believe patients are being misled
and confused on the other hand the large
laboratories believe that this is going
to be an onerous burden for them and
they have been lobbying a congressman
congressman berga jizz in particular to
remove FDA front oversight for
laboratory developed tests CMS opposes
this because CMS CLIA says they don't
have any expertise to determine clinical
validity that's not what CLIA does we've
all been asking CMS I'm n FDA what is
their definition of a laboratory
developed test because all of us over
time tend to modify our laboratory tests
we play around with pH or we play around
with a different specimen type and we do
the validation studies that we know how
to do pork Lea and believe that we can
we have not done any particular harm to
a fda cleared test FDA's definition
seems to say that those modifications
may require that we submit the test for
FDA clearance and that is something most
of us
do not have the capability of doing
there's a lot of concern about what will
happen if this is not done properly it
will stifle innovation and certainly is
going to slow down what happens with
genetic testing so this is another area
that we are watching very very carefully
cfda is supposed to be releasing the
next round of guidance we don't know
when that's going to happen and we hope
it will happen sometime this summer or
fall in the meantime FDA and CMS are
meeting together and are going to
crosswalk what CLIA does and what FDA's
clearance process does to determine
whether overlaps so that if laboratories
do have to submit any of their
laboratory develop tests they will not
be having to duplicate effort between
the two sets of regulation that has that
was just announced in march and that
effort is ongoing we're waiting to see
what what that looks like the other
thing that FDA raised major concerns
about was blue coast monitoring they
issued draft guidance on self monitoring
devices that are used at point of care
their concerns were too at first of all
individuals using these glucose monitors
at the point of care typically were
nurses lpns maybe even patient care
technicians it was not the patient and
they were using them between patients
and not cleaning them properly causing
infections to be transmitted from
patient to patient it had documentation
of the that and then also that there
were instances where drugs that were in
the IV's of the patients who were being
tested by these glucose monitors
interfered with the test strip gave
erroneous results and patients were
treated inappropriately and and in a
number of cases there were deaths that
occurred hospitals have been concerned
about the guidance
as it seems to remove wave status from
glucose meters and in essence that is
what what would have happened FDA
believes they should be considered
moderately complex tests and therefore
need to be proficiency tests and they
say at the same token and you don't have
this on your slide what happened was
excuse me the FDA went to I mean sorry
CMS issued a memo that said if you are
using those point-of-care waved glucose
meters on quickly ill patients they are
considering that off-label use and it
becomes a high complexity test now CMS
has since rescinded that memo but to add
to the confusion kids what they are
saying is while we rescinded the memo
the intent is still there and when we
questioned CMS about that what they
basically told us is what we mean by
that is that you still have to start to
quality control and and be careful about
who's using those point-of-care glucose
monitors because we don't consider using
them in on critically ill patients to be
approved usage by the label so see it
FDA has said that they want to see the
manufacturers resubmit their meters to
show what whether or not the leaders can
be used on subjects who are in critical
care settings who are receiving IVs and
other drug therapies multiple different
kinds to determine what happens to the
test results depending on what might or
might not interfere and that when that
labeling changes then FDA will
reconsider how to classify the devices
all of this is very uncommon if it is
what ALS has been telling its members is
if this is an issue in your hospital at
this point you should
at least re-educating everybody who's
using those point-of-care devices and
doing major validation studies for drug
and IV therapy interferences if you
cannot undertake that then the odds are
good you should figure out another way
to test patients glucose at the bedside
besides using those glucose meters I at
this point we can stop for questions I
see that there are some questions let me
take the first one is the gap on payment
reduction ten percent for 2016-17 and
two 20 19 or ten percent for each year
excellent question Todd we've asked that
question because we don't know one group
of us has read that as it's ten percent
for the collective years and another
group has read that to be ten percent
each year so in other words for 2017 ten
percent for 2018 ten percent for twenty
nineteen ten percent and then fifteen
percent for 20 19 through 2022 if that
really is the right interpretation we're
going to be paid nothing at the end of
20 22 just about so we're all hoping
that the initial interpretation is the
correct one that it's ten percent for
the first dose those two year get a gap
and then fifteen percent for the next
three years but we don't know for sure
and again we were hoping that when CMS
issued its regulations they would
clarify that the regulations have not
been clarified have not been published
the next question that I see is can you
elaborate on eq c and iqcp and when we
should start applying them okay so eq CT
is equivalent quality control and that
has been in effect and had been in
effect since 2010 when CMS first rolled
out this new concept of doing what would
be considered
in more efficient Lee structured quality
control so you didn't have to do quality
control every day they roll this out but
unfortunately they rolled it out without
a lot of scientific studies and no
evidence to explain how they came to the
decisions that they came to and they
said if your system was very very stable
you could actually not run quality
control for a month if you could prove
that the system was stable enough but
they didn't [ __ ] say how you were
supposed to prove that exactly except
that you had to show them validation
studies and that sort of thing and and
so the community at large was concerned
about this whole EQC concept and that's
when clsi stepped in and held a set of
meetings and said what else can we be
doing how else can we look at quality
control and they started talking about
looking at quality control based on the
risk of something sailing in your system
the risk of the incubator temperature
changing without you knowing about it
the risk of not enough reagent being
delivered for a given test you know all
those kinds of areas where your system
could sail on an instrument and then
quality controlling that area rather
than quality controlling just in general
with the two levels every day of testing
and that's how I qcp was born it was it
came from one of CLS eyes documents
called EP 23 iqcp n eq CP orb or both
voluntary they are not mandated by
regulation you didn't ever have to use
them you you could have just done your
two levels of quality control every
eight hours or every day of testing like
the regulation says but if you don't
want to do that if you want to be more
in control of your own quality
management system then you can no longer
use each UCP you have to develop your
own
I qcp program you have to have it in
place in place by the end of this year
because starting in 2016 if you decide
you don't want to do with the
regulations say you to do which is to
run and I keep repeating this because I
want you to understand you have a
fallback you don't have to do iqcp you
can just do with the reg say and run
quality control two levels of external
control every eight hours or 24 hours
and depending on your testing if you
don't want to do that and you want to do
something different you have to follow
an IQ you have to follow an icq process
and you have to have that plan in
writing available two inspectors when
they come to see your laboratory and
that's what CMS has posted on their
website this step I said got stuck by
step guidance as to how to implement
that if you so choose to go that route I
hope I answered that question is that
didn't please ask another question now
or we can talk about it when we're in
the in the alternate site where you can
ask more questions are there any
additional questions okay well i guess i
guess if there are no further questions
at this time look thank you for these
two for that informative presentation I
and also I'd like to thank our sponsor
LCLs for making days webcasts possible
and I encourage everyone to head over to
the community of learning following this
presentation to have the opportunity to
engage in live chat with a visa
pessimist and your peers and have
answers to any questions you may have
about the future of laboratory
reimbursements as a reminder today's
webcast will be available for on-demand
viewing through October of this year you
will receive an email from lab roots
alerting you windows
webcast will be available for replay we
invite you to forward that announcement
to your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event thank you very much
for attending and we'll see you next
time until then goodbye